throughout the series audiences watched
as the gang Sheldon Raj Leonard Howard
and Penny are forced to take the stairs
up and down in their apartment building
because their elevator goes unfixed for
years due to the way the set is built
there are spots the camera doesn't quite
reach as Kunal Nair the actor who plays
Raj recently revealed one of his
co-stars had a pretty disgusting habit
when it came to those unseen spots on
the stairs in an interview with the
Daily Express Nair dished on how Leonard
actor Johnny Galecki seemed to regard
the wall as his own personal trash can
whenever they were using the onset
stairs as the actor explained you run
back up the stairs that go nowhere and
then you walk back down as if it's a new
floor down there is nothing there's a
wall there where Johnny Galecki for 12
years would stick his chewing gum on I'm
not joking there you have it folks if
you're the biggest Johnny Galecki fan in
the entire universe then who knows
perhaps you can buy his used chewing gum
on the internet because he stuck it on a
prop wall for over a decade instead of
just finding a better way to dispose of
it